a new Legally Blonde movie and we got an
update straight from Elle Woods herself
Reese Witherspoon what do you want
Elle's story to be in this next chapter
I think she's a very beloved character
hi I'm Elle would you just want her to
go on a hero's journey like she does in
the first movie and I'm having a great
time working on it was so excited about
my meeting on Legally Blonde 3 today
that I wore my contras fries has been
teasing us fans for years before finally
confirming a third film but we're
definitely not mad at the bend and snap
posts or fashion flashbacks we now know
the third film's release date
Valentine's Day next year but what about
the plot so script is being worked on
yeah that's scripts but we haven't shot
anything as for the casting well recess
emojis are back some returning
characters and some new characters this
is gonna be good are you going back
what's the deal I can't imagine anything
that would be more fun yeah definitely
be up for it it's all a career I would
do another one
boo-bear nothing confirmed yeah let's
see oh would you go back yes excuse me
I'd be there in a heartbeat if I was
asked miss Whitman
I'll go no perm if I have to or I'll go
fool perm whatever they need I'll be
there
[Applause]
[Music]